يتلقى التلاميذ في دول اوروبا الغربيه
والولايات المتحده وكندا واستراليا تعليما
جنسيا يبدا من مراحل مبكره ادخلت امريكا
التعليم الجنسي للمدارس في خمسينيات القرن
الماضي لكن بدايه الدعوه لادخاله كانت منذ
عام 1912 وتظل الخلافات حول محتوى هذا
التعليم ايضا التثقيف الجنسي الزامي في
معظم الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
باستثناء بلغاريا قبرص ايطاليا ليتوانيا
بولندا ورومانيا والمملكه المتحده وفقا
لدراسه صادره عن البرلمان الاوروبي تقول
الدراسه ان المحتوى يختلف من بلد الى اخر
في النمسا مثلا يدرج الاباء في دروس
التربيه الجنسيه في هولندا تبدا التربيه
الجنسيه في سن الرابع بينما في بولندا
تكون الحياه الجنسيه من المحرمات في
المدرسه وفي اسبانيا نادرا ما يتم تدريس
هذا الموضوع في المناطق الريفيه في روسيا
والهند والصين لا توجد مواد جنسيه ضمن
مناهج التعليمي هناك
[موسيقى]